moving however it's important the house
is kept informed and villains in the
timely and authoritative way there are
legitimate questions requiring answers
about the functioning of government over
this turbulent period that is why i've
granted the uq we're about to hear i
remind all members that conventions and
curses are here for a purpose to allow
us to discuss the most important issues
without resorting to personal attacks
that is why i encourage all members to
remember our constituents are watching
events closely let us focus on the big
issues not the personality i now come to
the deputy leader for the uq angela
reyna
thank you mr speaker for granting this
very important uq today to ask the
minister for the cabinet office if he
will make a statement on the functioning
of government
minister ellis
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
as the house will be aware
it is widely reported that the prime
minister is about to make an important
statement shortly
i can confirm that it is correct that
the prime minister will speak shortly
i cannot preempt the prime minister's
statement
and the house and the nation will hear
more imminently
in the meantime
the business of government continues
supported in the usual way by our
excellent civil service
there will continue to be ministers of
the crown in place
including in all great offices of state
we must continue to serve our country
constituents and the general public
first and foremost
it is our duty now
to make sure the people of this country
have a functioning government
this is true now more than ever
the civil service
is the foundation on which all
governments function
the civil service continues to support
across all government departments and
the country
can be assured that this will always
remain the case
i have spoken this morning to the
cabinet secretary to that effect
any uh transitional arrangements have
always been made to allow for the
business of government to continue
there are constitutional mechanisms in
place to make sure that can happen we
await the prime minister's statement
but the house should be reassured
that the government continues to
function in the meantime
any necessary
ministerial vacancies can and will be
filled other secretaries of state can
make decisions if necessary
there is a rich reserve of people who
are both dedicated and talented and who
remain dedicated to serving our country
and their constituents
calmness and professionalism are now
required
our focus now
is fully on the stability and continuity
of government mr speaker
now is the time to serve in the
interests of our country as it always is
and our constituents during the period
ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
i hate to break it to the minister
but we don't have a functioning
government
it will be good news for the country
that the prime minister is to announce
his resignation he was always unfit for
office he has overseen scandal fraud and
waste on an industrial scale but the
chaos of the last three days is more
than just petty tory infighting these
actions mr speak have serious
consequences for the running of our
country in the middle of the deepest
cost of living crisis of a generation
with families unable to make ends meet a
dangerous war in europe threatening our
borders and a possible trade crisis in
northern ireland britain has no
functioning government no ministers in
place to pass legislation bill
committees cancelled with no one to run
them can the minister confirm whether
the 11 committees due to take place
today will go ahead without ministers
what are the arrangements to pass
primary and secondary legislation and
who will answer oral questions how will
this government continue to be
democratically held to account with the
new education secretary resigning after
36 hours which must be a record there is
not a single member in the department of
education
what does this mean for children taking
their exams what does this mean for the
impending child care cost crisis
and our british national security is at
risk too not least because the prime
minister thinks he can stay on with the
departure of the northern ireland
secretary only two ministers are left
able to sign security warrants to
approve secret service use of sensitive
powers what contingency plans are in
place to deal with emergencies in the
short term mr speaker the prime minister
has said he will stay on as caretaker
how many more months of chaos does this
country have to endure with dozens of
ministerial posts unfilled who on earth
will join the prime minister's
government now and how will a half empty
cabinet run the country until october mr
speaker they will try desperately to
change the person at the top but it's
the same old tory party in government
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker i cannot preempt
the prime minister's statement and uh
the house and the nation will hear more
very shortly
but government and the civil service
will continue to function in the
meantime
the the business of the house statement
will be made shortly and members can ask
questions of the leader of the house of
commons about the
the matter of the business of this place
but the house will continue to function
and government business will continue to
function other secretaries of state can
deal with uh issues for other
departments constitutionally and legally
in necessary circumstances